je te dis que c'est impossible de tout
le moins qu'il entend ccc comme les mecs
qui sont les seuls à voir des fantômes
et le sait quand il s'est mis à me
parler qui êtes vous je suis dans le
camp mec là tu vas prendre chez qui le
corps
on va cela qu'il fait graves
là dedans j'ai la peau de l'âne dans
shrek c'est parce que tu me plais
membres aux abois
salut voulais j'avais pas que la police
recruté gp m'ont dit ça fait une petite
soeur je vous préviens je vais pas
pouvoir déglingo tout le monde je vais
me coucher avec ma fille et vous coucher
avec ma fille ça n'a même pas traversé
tu veux que je t'en fous
c'est moi red hat a dit que c'est
impossible comment qu'il n'entendait
c'est comme les mecs qui sont les seuls
à voir des fantômes va pas fou et les
droits du corps est encore c'est moi et
maintenant je vais me venger mais tu te
souviens l'autre je reçois je suis m'a
dit que si je n'entretenais pas mon
corps il pouvait se retourner contre moi
et moi c'est arrivé j'ai pas de
poubelles mais là dedans j'ai la peau de
l'âne dans shrek
ça vous dirait de par le baobab de
bamako non je ne sais pas ce qu'ils au
jeu suisses hors jeu par jeu par jeu est
persuadé que son corps s'appelle alex
et que rex contrôle j'arrive acheteurs
connais pas tu arrêtes maintenant il n'y
a pas de règle
c'est un cerveau il commente encore
c'est pas l'un vers tu comprends mieux
je savais pas que la police recruté chez
playmobil
page 3 branches avec moi on ne triche
pas assez clair j'ai présenté ses soeurs
je vous préviens je vais pas pouvoir
déglingué tout le monde
un seigneur c'est ma mère
pourquoi tu fais ça joue
tu vas prendre j'ai jamais trop chaud
fini n'en avez vous coucher avec ma
fille ça m'a même pas traversé l'esprit
général sb mec t'es dans la merde
ces endroits